I am Nicholas be for reason TV today
we're talking Tootsie Marcus funk author
of victims rights and advocacy at the
International Criminal Court Marcus
thanks for coming thank you why did you
write the book you know I wrote the book
I spent some time in Kosovo spent two
years for the State Department on Kosovo
between I'm Department of Justice
employees so it did two years in Kosovo
and had an opportunity to see firsthand
the work of international judges
International prosecutors both in
closeable within within the Balkan
region as well Serbia Bosnia and so I
developed a really strong interest in
the topic of international criminal
courts and also international
prosecutions we're talking about the
hague we're talking about the
prosecution of criminals against
humanity what is the hague's record on
successful prosecutions well the hey
there a number of different courts in
the hague but in terms of the
International Criminal Court the record
which is situated in The Hague of course
the record is that in the last seven
years they have indicted they have two
cases and one ongoing trial the D yellow
trial which is ongoing right now so so
far no convictions but obviously we're
optimistic that that'll change in terms
of similar courts if you look at the ad
hoc tribunal for the former Yugoslavia
the icty tribunal they had over the
course of approximately 16 years they
were able to get 61 final convictions
which is in itself a decent number the
the sentences were perhaps to American
years a little surprising in a sense
that we have of the 61 some people over
20 got sentences of less than 10 years
and only 10 got sentences of more than
20 years when you compare the sentences
for for these individuals which at least
in terms of the principles of the court
are are some of the greatest committed
some of the most grievous crimes
imaginable on they they seem to be
pretty load a lot of American
observers why why is that why why did
why did the census come in you know if
you you can kill dozens of people
hundreds of people thousands of people
and walk out after 20 years I think it
fundamentally break boils down to a
different way of viewing what what the
what the sentencing structure is the the
judges are from the court have a
different view of the purposes of the
court and of course many people have
different views about why this is but we
observe in criminal trials in Europe and
also for that matter in international
trials that the sentences tend to be
lower than what what many American
observers might imagine that maybe
because maybe we're imposing too tough a
sense on some of our federal cases maybe
they're not imposing strong enough
sentences and that's that's one of those
topics that people can debate for four
days what you mention in the book or you
talk about the numbers and the weakness
of numbers when we're talking about
things like crimes against humanity
genocide other types of you know
horrible acts why are the number so bad
well I mean you can look at the example
of the Congo a conflict where you have
from around 1998 to 2003-2004 you have
some 3 million individuals have been
killed who died as a result of the
conflict and those are enormous numbers
they're really impossible to to grasp to
be honest with you and and so it is an
incredible task to try to address those
sorts of crimes I mean it's
extraordinary complex the cases are
complex the defendants are hard to get
physically in terms of getting
jurisdiction over them it's a great
challenge of prosecute I think those
kinds of cases and so whenever you have
numbers like that in terms of millions
of people who have been killed in
genocides or in war crimes crimes
against humanity what collectively refer
to as atrocity crimes you're really not
only going to get the people with
command responsibility and arguably
that's what the purpose of these
tribunals is is to pick off the people
who really in charge and not the mid or
lower level criminals I mean one could
argue that that in an ideal world we
would we would be able to convict all of
them but the realities are not that way
are these the types of crimes that
should be adjudicated it you know by the
international community or does it
always come down to you know that you
know these these would be better
prosecuted in in different forums
altogether well the question is what has
both a practical dimension and also it's
a philosophical dimension on the
practical dimension and I'm speaking
just you know as a observer of these
things not in my official capacity
obviously I'm happy to see criminals
prosecuted by whomever wherever they can
be prosecuted in other words if you have
provided people due process you've got
you've investigated a case properly
you've given people a fair trial whether
that's done at The Hague or whether
that's done in Darfur matters less I
think then that it gets done now that's
the practical view maybe this is me
speaking as a prosecutor over
emphasizing the practical view the sort
of the more the political view of course
is that there is the International will
and and for a lot of people that is an
important symbolic significance that the
international community comes together
and decides that this person is
deserving of the being arrested and
prosecuted in an international forum and
being subjected to the condemnation of
the international community people can
differ as to whether that is or should
be a motivator as opposed to the
practical but from my perspective I if a
domestic jurisdiction can prosecute
cases well and fairly by all means I'm
all for it isn't that the case that I
say in the former Yugoslavia and Lord
hopes not the future Yugoslavia would it
be better to have the you know the
criminals tried there by people to the
degree that they can be impartial to the
degree that they can understand the the
state
on every possible level it just seems
like a better fit isn't it then removing
people to a to a distant jurisdiction
and you talked about the international
community but I mean who speaks for the
international community is its people
from bar for is the people from
Yugoslavia well in many ways in the
International Criminal Court is to
reverse federalism paradigm I mean many
people view the International Criminal
Court is being the the court that's on
top of all other courts in reality
perhaps a better way of looking at is as
a catch-all cord it catches those cases
that cannot be prosecuted and and
investigated properly in the domestic
jurisdiction at least that is what the
purpose of the International Criminal
Court is and so is it better to
prosecute a case locally or domestically
on the basis of the International
Criminal Court the Rome statutes own
articles and rules it is the the default
position is the case gets prosecuted in
the home jurisdiction of the domestic
jurisdiction if the jurisdiction is
either unable or unwilling to prosecute
the case then it comes to the
International Criminal Court when I say
the case we're talking about cases to
qualify as atrocity crimes and so the
International Criminal Court statutory
framework builds in the assumption that
is preferable to have it done
domestically what is the United States
position to the ICC and what should it
be well that's that's what I'm not I'm
going to have to punt on or rather I'm
going to have to I'm not going to be
able to answer just because in terms of
what the u.s. position is right now I
can tell you what what the formal
position is that that the United States
obviously is an observer has been active
in in helping draft the the articles and
rules by which the ICC is governed has
made public statements as to
prosecutions as to what the future role
should be that is something that will be
decided what we are not an active member
we're not an we're not a member we're
not what's called a member of the
assembly of state parties we're not a
state to party to the ICC let me ask or
could you tell us very quickly what what
is your professional background that
that you ended up you were at the State
Department but how did you get there I
started as a law professor at Oxford in
England and then clerked and went and
joined the department of justice as a
prosecutor federal prosecutor in Chicago
I stayed there until about two thousand
four late two thousand four when had an
opportunity and was permitted by my boss
in Chicago to to go to the State
Department go to Kosovo and and coastal
I was what's called the resident legal
advisor essentially providing guidance
assistance research and so forth to the
both the chief of missions now the
Ambassador now the Kosovars formerly
considered a country and then also to
local legal actors and so that did that
until two thousand six and then I came
back to Chicago where I'm now in the
organized crime business section well
I'm not in the business as much as a is
trying to let mom hear about Chicago
here I here so I've seen on TV here and
there and thank you Marcus we've been
talking to t Marcus funk author of
victims rights and advocacy at the
International Criminal Court for reason
TV I'm Nick Gillespie